welcome to this year's Tamil lectures
before we actually begin can I just make
the usual important housekeeping
announcement please switch off your
phones with the word off their meaning
off rather than silent because the the
lecture is recorded as always and there
is always the risk that simply the phone
trying to pick up the signal even if
it's silent will suddenly blast out on
the recording so the Tamil lectures were
founded 40 years ago in 1978 the trust
deed for the Tamil lectures were signed
in Clare Hall Clare Hall is in many ways
the father of the Tanners lake tana
lectures the true father of course is
the man who made them possible Oh Burt
Tanner founder of the Tanner corporation
which still funds these lectures it
funds lectures in nine major
universities seven in the US and two in
the UK Oxford and Cambridge if you look
at the Tanner lectures website on
Wikipedia it will say what does say like
being invited to give the Tanner lecture
is basically a sign that you're at the
top of the tree the Tanner lecturers are
the top of the tree in thinking about
human values so we are both for the
origins but also continuously in the
debt of the Tanner corporation of Salt
Lake City for funding these lectures
around the United States from the UK
funding them generously so that we can
get the top rate speakers and in our
case respondents that we want now
today's speaker is Lee Bollinger Lee
started out life just as a law student
as many of us did he then became after
time the law clerk to
Chief Justice Warren burger chief
justice an American Supreme Court he
became professor at Michigan Dean of the
Michigan law school president of
Michigan law about Michigan University
1996 and has been president of Columbia
University since 2002 I would call soon
to blush by saying he is possibly the
most successful president in the United
States but I will not cause him to blush
by saying he is probably the most
long-serving
president in the United States so let's
leave it at that as well we have two of
our commentators here professor ray
Langston who is home from Newnham
College the Knightsbridge professor I've
got that professor John Powell who
arrived at about 3:30 this afternoon
from Berkeley so thank you both very
much for coming they will be giving
comments on the lecture tomorrow and we
also have a third commentator who will
appear over the cyber waves in front of
us all Fred shower from Virginia and
Harvard who is teaching a class at this
very moment worked out he couldn't in
fact arrive in Cambridge in time to both
to see the lecture and to do the
response to it tomorrow but he will be
watching the recording of this lecture
and preparing his remarks for tomorrow
when he will be on the big screen now
Lee as president / Michigan and at
Columbia has to show the toughness of a
CEO of a multinational company it's a
very very big business he also needs the
intelligence and sharp witted nurse to
be able to deal with faculty students
local politicians all of whom have got
different views there is no point just
telling them what to do
you have to argue with them what to do
and he has those those skills in spades
he is very good at that he knows
perfectly well because he's been in my
position of having to find Tana
lecturers he knows that this doesn't
qualify to be a Tana lecturer at all
there are many presidents of CEO of
multinational corporations who we
certainly wouldn't want to have as kind
of lecturers on human values his
qualifications at an a lecturer Center
in the work that he's done on free
speech and access to universities within
the United States university system he
is I think probably the second most
famous defendant in lawsuits before the
Supreme Court after wait whoever Wade
was Wade but they Supreme Court cases of
Grutter and Bollinger and grat symbology
on the legitimacy the constitutional
legitimacy of the admissions policies in
the Michigan law school when he was Dean
there are absolutely seminal leading
cases on diversity and equality in terms
of admissions to universities Michigan's
push for diversity reflects a great deal
of what is going on in UK universities
today and as happens in UK universities
today there are two sides to this
question through our those who want to
have a more diverse group of people and
those who are very happy to have a more
diverse group of people as long as it
doesn't disadvantage their own
particular group of people so Lee will
be very familiar with our world with
what goes on in our universities this
very day but it's not just in equality
and diversity in universities that he's
known for it's also for his
on free speech of freedom of the press
he's written several books on this and
he will be equally familiar with the
discourse that goes in are goes on both
in our public space and in our
universities in particular of the
friction between freedom of speech on
the one hand and a desire to suppress
hate speech on the other hand or in some
universities but I hope not this one
the desire to know platform certain
speakers whose views are unpopular so
Lee is one of the experts on this area
it's one of the most contested areas in
our world at the moment so it's wholly
fitting that we should have him giving
our Tanner lecture this year and his
title is the free speech century a
retrospective and a guide
[Applause]
thank you very much David we really
appreciate the introduction appreciate
knowing you and the association with
Clare Hall Cambridge let me begin by
acknowledging my wife Jeanne manana
Bollinger who was right here after 50
some years of marriage and you know she
is an audience of one for me
I just don't every time I think about
saying something it's with Jean and mine
I also really appreciate the other
people who are here and in particular
ray length and John Palin and Fred
shower it is a deep and meaningful honor
for me to deliver these Tanner lectures
especially under the auspices of Clare
Hall and Cambridge University it is
unlikely anyone here today except Jean
would know the layers of association for
me that make this particular moment much
more significant than the usual lecture
I might deliver in 1983 Jean and I
brought our two young children ages 5
and 9 here to live and work at Claire
Hall during a sabbatical from the
University of Michigan Law School we
discovered what so many others have as
well this gem of an intellectual and
personal home set in this magnificent
University and charming town which
altogether provides its visitors with
the magical out of time experience that
stays with one for life this special
bond was made still more special when I
was subsequently honored in 1999 1999 by
Clare Hall as an honorary fellow it is
also personally important to me that
when I was president the University of
Michigan which is also one of the sites
as David said of the tenor lectures I
too oversaw the lectures
and Jean and I always enjoyed our annual
meeting with the other presidents and
spouses of host universities in that
moveable feast of companionship we
became good friends and admirers of Dame
Gillian beer and her late husband John
so even though I know firsthand from
experience just how difficult it can be
to find Tanner lectures nevertheless to
be asked actually to deliver one and for
it to be with Clare Hall and Cambridge
University makes me feel the pleasures
that a former cast member of Saturday
Night Live feels upon being asked to
return as the host finally adding
further to the layers of special meaning
underlying this moment is the subject of
these lectures namely freedom of speech
and press if anything defines my life
scholarly work this is it trying always
to understand this extraordinary human
and social development through the prism
of the First Amendment to the United
States Constitution but it also defines
my life in a deeper sense
my grandmother began working as the
librarian in a small town daily
newspaper in the 1930s to support
herself and my father a young boy then
when her husband died prematurely my
father then followed her and began
working at the same newspaper first as a
paperboy and from there working his way
up the ladder this was in Santa Rosa
California and the paper was the Press
Democrat much later becoming for a while
a property of the New York Times I was
born in Santa Rosa and spent many hours
at the PD as it was called absorbing the
distinctive smells and whirling
activities of producing a daily
newspaper
later when I was a teenager my father
became the editor and publisher of an
even smaller small-town newspaper and
Baker Oregon I worked there as the
janitor and the developer of films among
other jobs breathing as can only happen
in that coming-of-age period the
atmosphere of journalism and the press
when I began my career as a young law
professor at age 27 at the University of
Michigan I turned almost instinctively
to the First Amendment as my first field
of focus was my field of focused
interestingly in the strange ways of
developing scholarly expertise the year
before as a law clerk to Chief Justice
Warren burger I had worked on one of the
major First Amendment cases involving
broadcast regulation so of course I
wrote my first article on what I saw as
the puzzle of differential treatment
under the First Amendment of newspapers
and the new media of television and
radio
the former protected against regulation
and the latter subject to an approved
regime of regulation following that I
undertook a more ambitious goal of
understanding the theoretical meanings
of the First Amendment especially in the
context of protecting extremists speech
which is what I pursued here in 1983
while at Clare Hall and which became a
book the tolerance society all my
subsequent writings and scholarship and
the teaching I do every year seem
solidly rooted in and based on these
glorious settings in which I was
afforded the gift of pursuing my
curiosity throughout my career I have
also been fortunate to have many other
associations with the areas of freedom
of speech and press I have served on the
board of the Washington Post Company
including the during the time in which
the newspaper was sold to Jeff Bezos as
president of Columbia I'm a voting
member of the board that selects the
Pulitzer Prizes a process I admire
greatly
as an academic leader in the odd way in
which life works I have had far more of
my share
free speech controversies and issues
than is fair and I have been involved in
more litigation about the First
Amendment that I care to recount
especially as a defendant all this
brings me to the subject of my lectures
this afternoon and to another layer of
meaning these lectures happen to
correspond almost perfectly with the
publication of a book my good friend and
longtime First Amendment colleague Jeff
stone the University of Chicago Law
School that we and he and I have been
working on for the past two years and
when in which Fred shower has a
wonderful essay it is titled the free
speech century and is published by
Oxford and I will draw on it for these
lectures we invited 16 scholars and
practitioners to reflect on the first
100 years of First Amendment
jurisprudence and to begin to grapple
with some of the most significant
questions we face now and will continue
to face in this next century framed by a
dialogue and epilogue between Jeff and
me the essays offer reflections and were
critiques of the first 100 years of
cases addressed some specific areas of
controversy like campaign finance campus
speech national security and publication
of state secrets assess the
international implications of First
Amendment jurisprudence and try to come
to terms with issues raised by the
newest communications technology namely
the internet and its various platforms
and search engines few people realize
that all that we take today as
constituting the rights of freedom of
speech and press in the United States is
really only a century in the making
not until 1919 in that period beset with
fears and
found feelings of insecurity arising out
of the First World War the Communist
revolution in Russia supposed
international conspiracies to subvert
democracy's labor movements and
immigration and foreigners did the
Supreme Court begin to decide what the
14 words of the first amendment quote
Congress shall make no law abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press
actually should mean in practice from
our perspective today one has to say it
began rather badly well the great
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. wrote
for an unanimous court in the opening
three cases that speech could only be
prohibited when the state could
establish a quote clear and present
danger of some evil within the
legitimate powers of the government to
do something about which seemed much
more protective than the prevailing
quote bad tendency test of the time the
actual application of the new test to
the cases before it was shockingly
casual when looked at with modern free
speech sensibilities as Holmes said
famously and of course correctly free
speech does not protect the person who
yells falsely fire falsely in a crowded
theatre but that's not a very positive
way to approach the task of trying to
locate the outer boundaries of political
discourse the most egregious of the
three decisions involved the prosecution
and of the leader of the Socialist Party
of the time and its candidate for
president of the United States Eugene
Debs
he delivered a speech in Ohio in which
he praised individuals who had illegally
resisted conscription the government
claimed that this violated the Espionage
Act of 1917 which made it a crime
willfully to quote obstruct the
recruiting or enlistment service
the United States his conviction was
upheld by the court Deb's was sentenced
to 10 years in prison during which he
received over 1 million votes in the
presidential election of 1920 it would
be as if Hillary Clinton were jailed for
her speeches within a matter of months
however Holmes began to have second
thoughts and to reverse his position in
a case involving five Russian immigrants
and always involved Russians involves
Russians who circulated a pamphlet in
New York City calling on workers in
ammunition factories to strike in
solidarity with the Communist revolution
in Russia Holmes dissented from the
decision finding a clear and present
danger and wrote these famous and
eloquent words persecution he said for
the expression of opinion seems to me he
said perfectly logical if you have no
doubt of your premises or your power and
you want a certain result with all your
heart you naturally express your wishes
in law and sweep away all opposition to
allow opposition by speech seems to
indicate that you think the speech
impotent as when a man or a person says
that he or she has squared squared the
circle or that you do not care
wholeheartedly for the result or that
you doubt either your power or your
premises but when people have realized
that time has upset many fighting faiths
they come to believe even more than they
believe the very foundation of their own
conduct that the ultimate good desired
is better reached by free trade in ideas
that the best test of truth is the power
of the thought to get itself accepted in
the competition of the market and that
truth is the only ground upon which
their wishes safely can be carried out
that at any rate he closed is the theory
of our Constitution it is an experiment
as all life is an experiment within the
decade justice Louis Brandeis had joined
Holmes as one of the most eloquent free
speech advocates most notably in the
1927 case of Whitney versus California
Anita Whitney had attended meetings of
the Socialist Party and was part of the
group that advocated a moderate
nonviolent platform well a more radical
wing advocated overthrow of the
government through revolution addressing
the question of how to conceive of
freedom of speech Brandeis wrote in
equally famous language about how quote
it is hazardous to discourage thought
hope and imagination fear breathes for
oppression that repression breeds hate
that hate menaces stable government that
the path of safety lies in the
opportunity to discuss freely supposed
grievances and proposed remedies and
that the fitting remedy for evil
councils is good ones he went on fear of
serious injury cannot alone justify
suppression of speech to free people it
is he said then he closed by saying men
people feared witches and burned women
it is the function of speech to free
people from the bondage of irrational
fears he went on those who won our
independence by revolution were not
cowards they did not fear political
change they did not exalt order at the
cost of liberty to courageous
self-reliant people with confidence in
the powers of free and fair less
reasoning applied through the processes
of popular government no danger flowing
from speech can be deemed clear and
present and less
the incidence of evil apprehended is so
imminent that it made the fall before
there is opportunity for full discussion
these words and thoughts of Holmes and
Brandeis ultimately won the day in the
United States but also in many nations
around the world over the course of the
20th century after another low point in
repression and censorship in the 1950s
when the McCarthy era and the then
pervasive fear of the Russian threat to
undermine American and Western
democracies the Supreme Court again
succumbed to national panic in Dennis
versus United States a majority the
court upheld the convictions of the
leadership of the American Communist
Party the crowning achievement of the
Holmes Brandeis perspective occurred in
the transformative environment of the
Civil Rights an anti-vietnam war period
of the 1960s and 70s in this epic
crucible of national transformation the
Supreme Court decided a series of cases
that together composed the modern idea
of free speech and free press the
decisions led by New York Times versus
Sullivan protecting the New York Times
against civil liability for running a
civil rights advertisement that made
false statements about the actions of
the police in Montgomery Alabama and
supported by Cohen versus California
protecting an individual wearing a
jacket in a public place with the words
the draft written across the back
Brandenburg versus Ohio protecting a
meeting of the Ku Klux Klan Pentagon
Papers protecting the New York Times and
The Washington Post in publishing stolen
government classified documents Red Lion
broadcasting versus FCC upholding
regulations broadcasting designed to
expand
viewpoints and Miami Herald versus
Tornillo rejecting regulations designed
to expand viewpoints in the context of
newspapers all these decisions and many
others created the most elaborate and
speech protective jurisprudence of any
nation in history with as I have
indicated positive influences around the
world a centenary always seems like a
natural time in which to step back and
consider what has happened over that
period and what it all means and should
mean in the future this is certainly
true with free speech and press we also
live in a moment of enormous social and
political change in the United States
and across nations which makes taking
stock a necessity
more than simply a convenient moment on
the historical calendar that is the
genesis of the free speech century the
book and the topic of these lectures in
this first lecture I want to continue
with the summary of the First Amendment
experience and more importantly offer
some observations on how to interpret
and understand what has happened then in
the second lecture I want to turn to the
present and future and consider three of
the most important questions of this
century one should the legacy of the
last century be continued and what are
its prospects given current political
and global trends towards authoritarian
regimes second what should be the
general approach to dealing with the
rising importance of the Internet and
its component elements which are now
widely perceived as increasingly
dominating in shaping the public forum
and third and lastly what are we to make
of the fact that the modern world is
increasingly interconnected and inner
pendant yielding problems and issues
that can only be resolved effectively
through collective international action
with a new truly global communications
technology to serve as the global public
forum but with vastly different
competing conceptions of free speech and
free press in contention in other words
how should we think about free speech in
a globalized world understanding the
last hundred years of free speech and
press in the United States is very much
about understanding how we should deal
with people who advocate illegal or bad
acts whether they be major such as
overthrowing the government or minor
such as taking over or occupying public
or private property context can shape
everything and this is the context that
has shaped our thinking about the First
Amendment there have been many proposed
tests for drawing that line besides
clear and present danger there is the
bad tendency test the Express incitement
test the idea that abstract ideas are
protected but not stealing people for
action the gravity of the evil
discounted by its in probability and
finally speeches protected until it is
directed at producing imminent lawless
action and likely to produce such action
this last formulation being the one we
live under today as I have indicated the
last 100 year history is one of a being
and flowing of protection with the
courts following the national mood since
the 1960s however the scope of
protection has generally been very
strong from this let me fill in the
First Amendment map the court has drawn
up for our world now of freedom of
speech and press
as the court expanded the protection for
speech advocating illegality it also
recognized the number of exceptions to
freedom of speech and steadily narrowed
them over time and so we have laws
protected by the allowed by the
Constitution the First Amendment we have
laws banning obscenity fighting words
libel threats invasions of privacy and
speech about risks of violence and
disruption caused by hostile audiences
the jurisprudence now has many cases
permitting and delimiting these
exceptions any notion of free speech
must also figure out it's what I call
horizontal dimensions not only what
words and language will be protected but
also what nonverbal communications once
you realize that all human behavior is
or can be communicative or expressive
you face the dilemma of how far to push
the First Amendment interest analyzing
government regulation of all conduct
this problem bedeviled the court and
analysts for decades producing all kinds
of analytically problematic solutions
the government cannot regulate the can
cannot regulate pure speech but it can
regulate action or conduct not
confronting the fact that all speech is
action or conduct and all action or
conduct is expressive eventually the
court settled on an approach that
focused on the government's motive
behind the regulations so if the purpose
is to stop messages or viewpoints no
matter what the conduct was then the
First Amendment would be fully deployed
if on the other hand the government's
motive or purpose has nothing to do with
the communicative impact of the behavior
then the government will be afforded
broad though not unfettered leeway to
regulate in practical terms this means
that free speech encompasses far more
than words
or language written or spoken and
therefore virtually all human behavior
is at least in theory protected against
state prohibition to the extent that the
states motive is in prohibiting the
ideas expressed through that behavior
the implementation of this approach has
required extensive intellectual
refinements adding to the intricacy of
the First Amendment jurisprudence
similarly and also on the horizontal
plane the court has faced the question
whether to extend the reach of the First
Amendment into realms of speech activity
beyond the traditional political public
forum namely to those realms like
Commerce and finance labor and
management the workplace the home and
personal areas of life and so on
in general the decision has been to
permit much greater discretion of the
government to regulate in these areas
while not withdrawing entirely and
keeping a First Amendment foot in the
door there's also a vertical dimension
in First Amendment analysis how should
we think about everything that might be
relevant to speech this can range from
having a right of access to information
under the control of the government to a
right of access to government controlled
spaces public streets and parks for
speech purposes can range to a right of
access to a good education in order to
be able to speak and discuss issues more
intelligently here the court has been
less forceful in pressing free speech
interest against other societal
interests streets and parks for example
must be available the so called public
forum doctrine but not many other venues
there are only limited rights of access
to information those involving judicial
proceedings notably there are three
other dimensions of First Amendment
jurisprudence worth special note the
first is especially important once you
have secured the scope of free speech
and press against censorship
you then face the question whether you
will leave things at that or whether you
will permit or even require the
government to intervene in the public
forum or the marketplace of ideas to
improve the quality of public discussion
there are many things that affect how
freedom of speech and press actually
function the allocation and distribution
of wealth through the economic system
the nature and distribution of
educational opportunities infamy or fame
discrimination against minorities and
certain groups and the effect of control
over the institutions that disseminate
information and opinion this is a very
very rich and complex subject but the
key thing I want to note is that the
experience of the last century includes
a major public effort of this kind
involving the public regulation of
broadcast media beginning in 1927 and
then being formulated reformulated in
1934 at the very origins of the new
technology of communication broadcasting
Congress established a federal agency
empowered to license and regulate the
medium consistent with the most general
mission statement to regulate according
to the quote public interest convenience
and necessity out of this system came
many public regulations most notably the
so called Fairness Doctrine which
required broadcasters to cover public
issues and to do so fairly with respect
to competing viewpoints in 1969 over
three decades from the inception of this
regulatory regime in red lion
broadcasting versus FCC the Supreme
Court unanimously upheld the Fairness
Doctrine and the general system saying
that the public's right to be fully
informed outweighed the interests of the
privileged few who happened to
control the outlets of broadcasting and
that the government had a proper maybe
even constitutionally required role in
helping to secure the public's right to
know in one of the most fascinating
developments in the jurisprudence some
five years later without ever mentioning
its decision in Red Lion the court
precluded any such involvement with
newspapers and print media that was in
Miami Herald versus Tornillo the
ostensible distinction between these two
outcomes focused primarily on the
physical limitations of the
electromagnetic spectrum the so-called
scarcity rationale which claimed that
the extremely limited number of
broadcasters physically possible due to
the nature of the spectrum justified
government intervention but this ignored
the fact that the economic realities in
newspaper business also produced an even
more monopolistic outcome in cities
across the nation in the 1960s over 90
percent of American cities had only one
daily newspaper but they would have
three VHF television stations and a
dozen radio stations in my view the
scarcity rationale was a fiction that
covered the desire to permit public
intervention in a limited portion of the
new highly monopolized mass media in
order to ensure and enhance the quality
of public discourse well this system
remains in place to this day the rising
political antipathy to any form of
public regulation of any kind beginning
with the Reagan era and continuing
through in American politics to this day
has reduced the significance and scope
of broadcast regulation for example the
Fairness Doctrine was eliminated by the
FCC in the late 1980s but not by any
means
eliminating the regulatory regime a
second area I would like to highlight is
that raised by the Pentagon Papers case
which is illustrative of the willingness
of the court to check government power
and to be highly inventive in doing so
every nation needs to figure out how to
strike the balance between allowing the
government to operate with appropriate
secrecy and how to ensure that the
citizens have the appropriate
information they need about their
government which will always be too
inclined to act in secret to exercise
their sovereign responsibilities
Pentagon Papers and a few accompanying
decisions established a completely
unique so far and so far as one can
judge such things entirely successful
solution to this problem like the dual
system of the press and media created by
redline and Miami Herald this one was
based on systemic and institutional
judgments of a highly pragmatic variety
not one wedded to simple notions of
logic or an insistence that everything
alike must be treated alike without
opportunities for experimentation or for
taking account of how people in
institutions actually function in the
world the question asked is this how
will the system work in practice not
what system is logical apart from the
practice without going into this in
detail the solution was this the
government will have full control over
its information with virtually no formal
right of access by the press to that
information leakers if pursued and
apprehended which in practice rarely
happened may be subject to criminal
penalties without any First Amendment
protections the press finally even when
it knows that it is receiving purloined
information from leakers will have
virtually full
detection to publish what it chooses
it's all the more interestingly
ambiguous than this actually suggests
creating subtle calculations each player
has to make in this very serious game of
national security and the public's right
to know up until recently at least it is
fair to conclude that this method of
balancing interest has worked without on
reasonable disclosures of classified
information and with reasonable
publication of classified information
important for the public to know the
third and last general observation is
about the range of methods the court has
followed in inserting the First
Amendment into areas of government
regulation sometimes the court has
weighed in in a given case in a given
area of controversy nor in given areas
of controversy in essence just the
signal of the presence of free speech
interests the hostile audience cases are
an example of this but sometimes the
complexities and doctrinal refinements
resulting from the court having taken
extensive number of cases and issued a
number of holdings is remarkable this is
notably true with respect to the areas
of libel and campaign finance which are
labyrinthine in their doctrinal
complexity it is in other words worth
bearing in mind how there are very
different strategies reflected in the
jurisprudence to close this first
lecture I want to make a few final
observations that will be important to
the subjects of the next lecture lecture
it is a vital element of the history of
free speech and free press in the United
States but it has fallen to our been
taken up by the judicial branch of
government context is always important
and here the context includes the very
special characteristics of the judiciary
lifetime tenure decisions limited to
cases and controversies the
self-restraint and self-education of
star a decisis or precedent
the mandatory norm of principled
decision-making supported by reason and
the necessity of explanation in detailed
opinions all of these things are
critically important of course we know
that standing somewhat apart from the
political fray permits at least in
theory a greater awareness of and
resistance to the misleading passions of
the moment given all of these qualities
and other virtues it is easy to reach
the conclusion that lodging the
development of the rights of free speech
and press in the judicial branch gives
you the greatest chance of having the
kind of social and political life you
seek despite the risk that this will
make other branches perhaps less
attentive than they might otherwise be
if they bore the primary responsibility
for securing those rights I share this
conclusion about the importance of the
judicial branch and it is clear to me
that if you seek the most effective law
of freedom of speech and press you
should first seek an independent
judiciary but I also think that we need
periodically to look at what the judges
have come up with and ask for more when
we think that is needed I feel that way
about how we have defined and
articulated the core purposes of the
First Amendment homes as we have seen
began the whole venture by linking free
speech to the search for truth but it
was Alexander Michael John in the late
1940s who dismissed that relationship
and argued instead for what he portrayed
as a much more practical relationship
between freedom of speech and the
responsibilities of self-government and
democracy this democracy rationale took
solid control of the jurisprudence in
the seminal decision in 1964 of New York
Times versus Sullivan and as a remain so
ever since for judges and justices who
may always naturally feel a little
sensitive about introducing broad quote
values into constitutional
interpretation
saying that enforcing free speech
against government regulation is simply
fulfilling the more fundamental
constitutional commitment the democratic
self-government can be appealing but it
is far too limited the role and meanings
of the First Amendment are really
multifaceted and they should be
recognized as such there is much more at
stake and much more to protect in
particular while the political area is
critically important for free speech so
too is the system for the generation and
preservation of truth and knowledge this
system composed primarily of colleges
and universities but also of
journalistic enterprises which seek
understanding far beyond the political
sphere and other institutions like
museums has yielded more benefits in
contributions to modern life than any
other and it's autonomy from the
violations of improper government
interventions is just as important as
that of citizens engaged in the
activities of self-government seeking
truth is not some abstract idea but
rather one with highly practical
operations and consequences nor is it
just some individual interest we have an
elaborate system of institutions with
all of the corresponding norms and
cultures developed over time
specifically designed to perform this
social need and public good and even
though there may not have been as many
cases rising raising threats to this
system there have been some and they're
likely to be more and it is time to
recognize this system as both fragile
and in need of the shelter of the First
Amendment Michael John ironically
because he was a lifelong academic was
too narrow in his conception of freedom
of speech we should not let those
notions to limit the scope of the First
Amendment and finally another area where
I believe we have allowed ourselves to
be too one-dimensional in thinking about
the
significance of free speech is with the
protections afforded extremist speech
these cases often have arisen in the
context of spiraling social fear and
panic leading to grave acts of injustice
committed against Ana scapegoating of
people and groups who are often marginal
individuals and relatively harmless
dissenters this is what both Holmes and
Brandeis were trying to address Holmes
saw Holmes saw how quote logical it is
for us to persecute people we believe
wrong especially in times of war and
national stress Brandeis has comment
that quote people or men feared witches
and burnt women graphically graphically
captures the breath of this impulse to
unjust intolerance none of these
feelings that lead us to persecute or to
be excessively punitive towards others
is limited just the speakers and speech
women were burned because of irrational
fears of what they might do namely
casting spells something that if it
actually existed would have nothing to
do with free speech but men feared bad
behavior where there was none and
committed crimes out of intolerant minds
it is that mind we are trying to change
at least when it rears its head in the
zone of free speech and is the very
generality of our bad impulses that
makes insisting that we refrain from
giving in to them in the realm of speech
perhaps exhibiting extraordinary
self-restraint all the more significant
and powerful the stopping of censorship
in these cases therefore is more about
our concern
about the reactions to speech than it is
with our wanting to protect speech as
such and to say this is the speak about
our character our self understanding and
not about protecting bad speech as some
unfortunate byproduct of our wish for
good speech I have called this the
tolerance theory of the First Amendment
and it is one of the many facets of this
amazing principle of freedom of speech
and press that has taken on such
extraordinary significance in the first
century of his jurisprudential life in
so many ways through this process of
creating an elaborate set of doctrines
and reactions to the on-the-ground facts
of multiple controversies the value of
freedom of speech and press has become
far more than a legal rule more even
than a constitutional law it has become
part of the very identity of what it
means to be American
[Applause]